generalization all right so just
presuming we're where Sasha finished off
so we're looking at some other
approaches to analyzing generalization
performance of prediction methods beyond
just considering empirical risk
minimization so settings where we're not
necessarily thinking about that sort of
approach of encode our prior information
into a function class and then try and
find the best fit to the data in that
function class so in in particular in
this section I'll talk about some local
local methods things like nearest
neighbor methods and kernel smoothing
methods and with the intention of you
know providing a bit of a high-level
glimpse maybe of the analysis techniques
for those sort of methods which are
quite different from the analysis of
things like empirical risk minimization
so two things we got to look at okay
nearest neighbor and and local smoothing
and here instead of thinking of a
proximation estimation trade-off this
there's a different kind of bias
variance decomposition as I say we're
not fixing a class we're relying on on
properties of the probability
distribution and in particular things
like if we're in a regression problem if
we work with quadratic quadratic loss
it's the conditional expectation that
we're pursuing and and we're relying on
properties of that conditional
expectation our regression function f
star like you know it doesn't vary too
rapidly as we move through the space so
maybe it has a Lipschitz property that
if you only move epsilon far then F star
only move some constant times Epsilon
and and you know the intuition for these
sort of local methods is that if you see
a new X and you want to make a
prediction there then you go back to the
data and and look at you know what
happened in the neighborhood of that X
what did nearby what was the Associated
label for nearby points or response for
nearby points
whatever nearby means okay so let's
start with this this bias-variance kind
of picture so you know as as before so
we have our FN hat that's our prediction
rule you can think of it as something
that you know given the training sample
that we've seen these X Y x1 y1 through
xn yn it's something that takes a new X
and makes a prediction and we're
concerned with the expected loss on a
new X Y pair and the expectation of that
I guess we're considering across across
the samples and we'd like that to be
close to the Bayes optimum so this F
star is the is the best possible
prediction rule in the sense of
minimizing this this loss and we saw
cases where we didn't really need to
think too hard about this bias variance
decomposition the approximation
estimation break down we were just
saying fix a class like linear functions
in D dimensions right with where n is
much bigger than D and you know as long
as we get it fine find some good fit to
the data then then you know that
generalizes in more interesting problems
you often want to explicitly consider
that trade-off you know we want to think
well actually we'd like to be able to
compete with something much more complex
than just a D dimensional thing you know
we might introduce a complexity
hierarchy across across functions for
instance you know and consider the
trade-off there between you know going
to something more complex where we get a
lower lower bias or a better bit smaller
approximation error at the possible
expense of having you know bigger bigger
fluctuations a bigger penalty for that
statistical task of finding the best
function in a in a bigger class so this
is the way we were thinking of things
before we had this approximation
estimation trade-off you know the
approximation part is because we're
picking a class and trying to find the
best in the class
sorry so this is the approximation part
and then the estimation part depends on
you know the scale of that of that class
and you know and you can think about of
that in a model selection sort of
setting in maybe one of such as talks he
mentioned this where there is this more
or less explicit balance between these
two trade off between these two we're
going to look at a different kind of
trade off a different bias variance
decomposition and you know it's a kind
that that in nonparametric statistics is
is totally routine we're going to work
with Square loss because it's it's very
convenient all right so we'll get an
explicit decomposition that's that's you
know really nice with Square loss we're
not fixing a class we're fixing a
procedure you know a method right so
it's something that typically has some
tunable parameter which is analogous to
a complexity parameter for a class but
again there's no no fixed class it's
like a you know band width parameter or
a roughness of our f n hat sort of
parameter you know it's that that that's
the thing to keep in mind when we when
we mess with this this particular knob
and you know and we're interested in the
trade-off that we get between between
bias and variance in this case
okay so just just to remind you in the
case of square loss the conditional
expectation is the Bayes prediction rule
a conditional expectation of Y given X
and so we can split our excess risk
right the expected loss for whatever
this method predicts versus the Bayes
risk that's the expected squared error
where this expectation is over X Y and
the sample that went into choosing FN
hat and this is the the base risk we can
split that up into you know put an F
star in here and and and subtract it
away again and then we get you know this
square term is this square term there's
this term which is the expected squared
difference of these two and there's a
cross term but of course that goes away
right because we can condition on the
X's and F star of X is the conditional
expectation of Y given X so you know
that times anything that's a function of
X has an expectation
okay so you know our excess risk is just
this this kind of l2 distance between
these two functions the one that we we
predict with and the F star and now
we're going to do a bias variance
decomposition looking at that that kind
of quantity in one more slide yeah so so
okay so let's think first of all about
that expression you can think of it as
you know it's as I said it's an
expectation over X X here the Y's have
gone away but it's also an expectation
over the sample writing that explicitly
you know here's the expectation over X
and that's a thing you can think of that
as a squared distance between FN hat and
F star and there's an expectation over
the sample as well all right so we can
we can you know off often what we'll do
is for this squared distance we'll
analyze that quantity right so we're
we're interested in the I said that
badly we're often interested in for a
fixed X seeing what this looks like and
then saying you know then what happens
on average across the exit okay and we
use this notation l2p for that squared
distance between between two functions
actually I think we're going to drop the
notation in a second and just write it
as a norm squared right and then here's
the bias-variance decomposition that
we're talking about in this part so so
this is the quantity we care about it's
this expectation over the sample of this
l2p distance between our prediction rule
and the best possible and we're going to
split that up into you know FN hat has
some dependence on the the x1 through xn
and some dependence on the y1 through yn
right we're going to pull out just what
happens for these Y's and consider the
expectation right under the choice of
the Y so conditioned on the X's and just
look at the expectation of the choice
the Y's are what you predict and you
know we're adding and subtracting that
but then we can write that as as this
sort of expectation all right again
because it's a conditional expectation
and then no other ways inside and so we
have two terms here
all right there's there's a
expectation over the over the sample of
the prediction here versus this averaged
prediction right so you know if we if we
knew the conditional distribution right
then this is the average of those
predictions so this is a variance term
this one is just the expectation of you
know what that averaged prediction is
versus the the F star so this is a bias
term right the best best prediction
would be F star and we're doing an FN
hat that maybe it varies a lot depending
on what those Y's are the noise in the
in the labels we see in the sample
you know this terms capturing that
variance but you know if we if we could
get rid of that variance and compute the
average then this bias is looking at
that piece of the puzzle okay
and typically you know as I say we have
maybe a bandwidth parameter or something
of that sort to vary and and you know if
as we make our FN hat smoother this term
is going to go down right we'll have a
lower variance thing but we pay in terms
of the violent bias because we're
washing out the predictions that we we
should be making in the variation in
those predictions gets gets eliminated
by having a smoother prediction rule you
know typically people would choose such
a parameter via via cross-validation I'm
actually not going to talk at all about
those kinds of choices alright so any
questions about this bias variance
decomposition this is really central
all clear so let's talk about these two
different cases k nearest neighbor and
we'll get on to kernel smoothing in a
moment so the K nearest neighbor
presumably everybody knows how that
works right we're in a metric space
we're going to say we're going to
consider Euclidean norm but you know all
we're using is a Lipschitz property so
it doesn't matter what you what metric
space you choose we're going to tailor
our assumption to it so we're in this
metric space and and you know we come up
with a new X and decide how do we
predict for that X well we here's here's
our new X we want to come up with a
prediction based on our our sample where
we find you know and these this is our
this is our data we find the the K
nearest point suppose K is 3 right so we
would look at the Y's that were
associated with these three closest
points and predict the average of them
right so it's 1 over K so we use this
notation the the order statistics
notation right where X sub 1 in
parentheses here means the X that's
closest to little X the test point ok so
you know this this indexing of course
depends on the test point okay so this
is the pair the XY pair that's closest
to our X that's this one and then
there's the second closest and so on and
for K nearest neighbor we just picked
the average across the K closest okay
all right so that's the prediction
strategy what about these two these two
components are their XS
risk so the variance component is is
considering our predictions versus the
average of our predictions you know
under this choice of the labels in the
sample a conditional expectation given
everything else so of course you know
that's just the the average so the FN
hat is predicting why for the for the
closest k guys the the average of the
Y's for the closest K guys the
expectation of that given the X's that
we saw is just F star right so every
every one of these the conditional
expectation of the Y associated with the
closest point is just F star at that at
that X right there sighs you know the
conditional expectation they're working
on square box so you know so that's
really nice the variances is controlled
and in particular goes down as we
increase K okay so by taking a bigger
and bigger average across these these
closest points if we include more and
more of them we get we get a smaller
variance the variance goes down like 1
over K okay so the bias part there's
more work to do so the the bias part is
comparing comparing this term to F star
and you know just just thinking about it
of course if if this is averaging more
and more of these case then we're
washing out our predictions much more so
we would expect things to get worse as K
gets bigger right we expect to be to be
further from the right prediction so you
know there is this trade-off as we
adjust this knob in this case it's K
it's the number of nearest neighbors we
consider all right so what's the biased
part look like so that expectation of
course is f star of X I the ithe nearest
guy versus F star of the test point so
we're considering you know how does F
star change as we move from the test
point X to these K nearest neighbors of
X so you know here we introduce an
assumption we're always going to have
this something in some sort of
assumption about P in in this sort of
analysis the assumption here is that f
star is
Lipschitz let's say one Lipschitz right
so we don't have Costas floating around
so we kept stars one Lipschitz then we
can write the squared bias this quantity
well I guess first of all there's a
instance inequality and then we're
saying okay the square of this thing
right is is bounded by the squared
distance between those two because of
the Lipschitz assumption alright so if X
I is nice and close to 2 X then the
Lipschitz assumption means F star can't
move very far when we move from X to X I
okay and so you know this term is nice
and small so so the the bias is governed
by how close these K random points are
to to X and as we increase K you know
they're going to get further and further
away okay so I'm gonna wave my hands a
lot in the next two slides so you know I
guess maybe not this is this is actually
quite precise and then although man so
so you know it turns out if you so what
we will care about here is just how far
these K nearest neighbors are from X the
the test point X so all we really need
to know is how close the closest point
is among some some finite set of points
and the way to see that is we'll get a
you know what appears to be a sort of
loose upper bound will say you know
instead of picking the K closest points
let me take my end points split them up
into K different bins in in an arbitrary
way I just fix them the first the first
n over K the next n over K and so on and
instead of picking the K closest I'm
going to pick K points that are the
closest in each one of those sets all
right so I'm doing something suboptimal
here I'm saying don't pick the K closest
pick the closest in each of those case
it's in a fixed partition of the end
points right and and certainly this
gives me an upper bound I'm not going to
be if this is the closest one in the ice
bin I'm not going to be as close as the
ice closest fine I'm giving something
away and then you know just take an
expectation all we care about is
you know what is the the expected
squared distance to the closest point in
a set of size n over K that makes sense
I'm saying instead of looking at the K
nearest points I'm going to take my set
of size N and I'm going to split it up
into K sets you know maybe that's one
set maybe there's some other set down
here of size n over K some other set
like this and so on right in this case
three and then I'm saying don't pick the
K nearest neighbors and look at this
quantity pick the nearest from the the
nearest from each of these so that would
be that one from this element of the
partition and that one from this element
and that one and I'm saying if we do
that you know rather rather suboptimal
thing we get an upper bound we're not
making any work any better right because
these were the nearest own is just
whatever fixed thing I want to do let's
say the first n over K the second in
over K in the sequence 1 2 n so nothing
to do with the ordering of distances or
anything it's a pro I fix and then we
just need to you know consider the
expectation but of course for each of
these it's just pick a set of size n
over K and and look at how far the
closest is yeah remain constant
so here we're considering in as a fixed
thing okay is a is this parameter of our
K nearest neighbor method these are
fixed and I guess I'm assuming that
these bins have all the same size it's
no big deal if one of them you know a
little less than n over K but right okay
so so so you know this is just a
simplifier problem right it means we
only need to care about the expected
squared distance between X and the
closest point in a fixed in a random set
of size n over K we just picked out one
closest point so we're getting away from
the K nearest neighbors to just what's
the one nearest neighbor and and that's
something this this is where I wave my
hands if the support is bounded and
we're in a high enough dimension then we
get the expected squared distance from
from a point from a particular
distribution and the closest point from
the same distribution for that expected
square distance goes down like the
number of points we're considering I
wrote it as n here to the power minus 2
over D all right so square distance so
distance is like n to the minus 1 over D
so this is bounded support and we're
making another assumption about P right
and and and you know you can get an
upper bound of this sort I mean this is
kind of terrible right it's a terrible
right this is 1 over n to the 1 over D
as d gets large this is very very slow
but equally we're making a very weak
assumption just that F star is
literatures and so you know I said n
here for a set of this is the closest
point in a set of size n so we have sets
of size n over K so this thing goes down
like n over K to the minus 2 over D and
and plugging that together with the bias
plugging that these two terms together
the bias and the and the variance
together we get the variance goes down
as K increases and the bias goes up as K
increases and you know if you pick the
right the a choice to optimize this
bound at least then
the combination of the two looks like n
to the minus two over two plus T and and
then we just integrate across across
axis to say that the expected squared
distance which is you know equal to the
quantity you would care about right the
excess prediction risk for this K
nearest neighbor method above the
optimal goes down like n to the minus 2
over 2 plus T questions years
you mean rather than this sort of
analysis no I think you get the this is
the right rate yeah this is optimal so
you know we didn't lose very much by
splitting it into these into these sets
in an arbitrary way and picking the
closest you know so if we introduce
other assumptions about about the
probability distribution we can get we
can get faster writes you know if you're
if you're willing to assume more about
it based on what they're living
Lipschitz y'all some kind of influence
so no no you get you get a faster rate
in that case I mean you there a there
you know I I actually don't know the
details but I know that you can get the
the number of derivatives that you have
download in this way appearing in the
exponent and I you I don't remember
these things may be such a do you
remember the it's it's it's into the
minor it across us is it just is it do
good to people to thank you right yes
plus D and we had s equals one thank you
if you use some sort of projection
method can you so so these are many
makes optimal rates for you know under
these assumptions so if you're willing
to assume you have this many derivatives
bounded then you know it's end of the -
this many and there's there's no
possibility there upper lower bounds so
so you know the answer is no under these
assumptions
all right so the other case oh so all
right so so you know with an appropriate
choice of K and and we saw that that
depended on on N and it depended on you
know if we look at a more refined result
depends on the sort of degree of
smoothness that we're willing to assume
this sort of analysis you know where
we're making an assumption about the
probability distribution and you know
then studying this bias-variance
decomposition for this specific method
it's very different from from thinking
about impersonal risk minimization over
some class of functions and you know how
close expectations are the sample
averages and so on it really is an
analysis that it's peculiar to the sort
of local nature of this sort of
prediction method so okay so there was a
compact support assumption on the the X
marginals and then this this Lipschitz
assumption on their conditional
distribution these are the these are the
things that the assumptions we needed to
make them to work for this enough
all right so moving on to the other
example I wanted to cover this is local
kernel regression so kernel smoothing
kind of approach so again it's local
where we're using the data that we've
we've seen in a neighborhood of the of
the test point to make predictions about
that test point so this is the another
area Watson estimate so we fix a kernel
maybe it's one of these one of these
functions we're going to assume that
there's a sort of bounded support for
this kernel so you know so things that
you might want to do like an exponential
a Gaussian kind of a thing let's just
truncate it right so it makes very
little difference if we if we truncated
far enough away but this is an
assumption that we'll we'll use for the
analysis or maybe you know you want to
consider some other some other kind of
kind of kernel and this is the way that
we wait nearby nearby points right so so
in this case the parameter that we have
to play with is a bandwidth parameter
it's it's varying how wide this this
shape is there in the scaling on the X
so we consider this fixed kernel
function evaluated at X scaled by H
right so if H is very large we have a
very pointy kernel if it's if it's small
we said that backwards right if H is
very large we have a very smooth ke sub
H and if it's small we have a very very
tightly concentrated thing okay and so
this thing is zero outside outside H
right if you're if you're considering so
the way things are going to work is
we're going to use this as a weighting
function about every point we saw in the
sample and so if we're if we're further
than H from that point it's going to
have no impact at all okay
okay and and actually the other
assumption we're going to make is just
just that these k's are also bounded
from below and and we'll see where this
kind of thing slips into the analysis
too
okay so what does the estimator look
like well so we have our our excise what
whatever they look like and each one has
an Associated Y I and then we're
considering this estimate which is a
weighted sum the weighting depends on
the test point X so let's let's put our
X in here the weighting depends on that
test point X and it gives us the weight
associated with each of the Y I so
here's here are few X's and the weight
is we place a kernel around I should
have done this in one dimension so let's
uh let's simplify right we place a
kernel around our our our training
sample so we have you know maybe this is
X this is an X here there's another one
here and another one over here and our
kernel is something that looks like you
know one of these one of these functions
whatever something like that right so
it's this thing and this thing and this
thing and this is not a very interesting
case right so it's only only x2 that
plays any role here because all the
others are more than H away from X right
but if if we had several of them with
this non zero then we'd be taking the
weighted average of the label associated
with many of them so suppose we had a
bigger value of H then we might we might
look at something like this and this
yes and then we'd be taking an average
of these two whites and the average
depends on you know the value of the
kernel at oh I'm sorry at this test
point here right we get a weighted
average according to the values here all
right so this is a number between
between zero and one all right that
gives us how much attention they give
give that that tells us how much
attention we're paying to the y
associated with that particular X I okay
is that clear you like work
okay so here the the bias is nice and
easy to estimate so the conditional
expectation of our predictions when we
average over these these wise and fix
everything else right we're just taking
the expectation of these wise weighted
according to to the X well that's just f
star at the X I times the weight that we
associate with that X I for the test
point X okay and so if we subtract f
star you know this is a convex
combination of of the f star x i's right
and and and so we could think of it as a
convex combination of the differences
between F star and X I and F star and X
what we should have predict the ideal
prediction okay and and you know this
this makes our life very easy to to make
this assumption that the support is
bounded by H you know this thing is
going to have a weight of 0 if X is more
than H from X star X the test point is
more than H from X I should say right so
if you're outside a radius of H right
then then we don't see then we get a
zero weight and and and so the biggest
difference that f star can can have in
here between a point X and a point X I
that's no more than H away is is H
because it's a 1 Lipschitz function so
it's H H squared is the biggest squared
value of this thing that we can see
oh good okay so that's the bias what
about the variance so here we're looking
at this is the conditional expectation
when we've given everything except the
Y's and this is our actual prediction
and we want to know what's the expected
squared difference so let's look at this
difference you know these guys are the
weighted Y eyes right weighted according
to how far X is from that that X I and
and the expectation here is the weighted
F stars okay so we can take the
expectation of the square of that
quantity and you know again the cross
terms are 0 and we take the expectation
of this we get that additional
expectation given the X I and and and so
you know this is what it looks like and
so we're left with thinking about you
know the weighting the weighting squared
in in this in this sum okay so so what
is that sort of expectation going to
look like you know the the conditional
expectation of this thing is just
whatever it is right it's some it's some
constant so all we really care about is
this is this quantity okay so you know
again
wave wave my hands here so that under
some assumptions on the the density of
the the marginal density of the X's we
get something we we get that this ratio
looks like something order of 1 over N
times H to the D where D is the
dimension and and when we plug that in
like we get for again an appropriate
choice of H this bandwidth parameter we
get a sum of two terms is like n to the
minus 2 over 2 plus D all right which is
the same rate we saw in there okay so to
two different cases where we've got this
sort of smoothness parameter K the
number of nearest neighbors and H the
bandwidth of these kernel smoothing
estimators all right
maybe but they're both minimax you know
under this assumption right so you can't
hope to get a better estimate without
any more assumptions than just the
Lipschitz one and and you know some
density assumptions that would kind of I
guess convenience so the marginal
distribution on X I guess is not the you
know it's not something to focus on at
least here so so you know maybe maybe it
seems more seems like it should be a
better a better estimate turns out
that's not the case under these
assumptions we're getting the same rate
that's right this is all rates this is
talking about rates and not saying
anything about that constants is saying
what's the rate as n increases the rate
at which you're going to hope to
oscillate this wet difference between
your prediction
it's Arabic right is that what you meant
yeah I just towards what people
experiencing the Oasis I see my right I
mean you know is is the will adversarial
is choice a probability distribution
that's all minimax maintance right under
these assumptions pick the worst for the
for your estimator
yeah
for the questions okay all right so
that's all I wanted to say about those
those kinds of smoothing methods the
last part is all about a phenomenon that
really has emerged from from deep neural
network practice you know that I think
is really is really pretty pretty
fascinating from the theoretical point
of view again seems like it's far from
the the kind of approach where the the
style of analysis of empirical risk
minimization where we consider you know
deviations between expectations and
sample averages for some class of
functions you know it seems like we're
far from from from that world with with
this phenomenon of interpolation so okay
so the observation is is this that in
practice people seem to Train deep
networks to zero training error and and
you know we saw in Sasha's talk this
morning that situation for
classification but here you know the
same could be said for a regression loss
like like squared error right so if you
if you train a deep network or anything
to have zero regression loss zero
squared error you're getting it exactly
right on the on every training example
there's there's no there's no more
there's nothing more you can do for the
for that training set so there's no
notion of a trade-off between fit to the
data and complexity right you can't
trade two things off if you're doing
that absolute best you can with one of
them okay so you know that's a strange
that's a strange thing but I guess the
the really surprising thing is you get
you get good performance out of this so
this is something that a lot of people
were talking about at there was a
Simon's Institute program on foundations
of machine
two years ago and in the bootcamp Russ
salakhutdinov was talking about you know
here's here's an approach that people
use in practice you have a data set you
come up with a network use the data set
to to choose parameters of that network
with stochastic gradient method if you
can't get to zero zero training error
you pick a bigger network all right
until until you've got an architecture
that's powerful enough to get things
exactly right on the training data
this sounds like madness but it turns
out you know you can get so and then the
rest of the story was and then you back
off a little in some sense add in a
little regularization or something else
and you get some slight improvements
that way the really striking thing is
they're slight improvements but you're
actually doing doing really well by
having zero regression loss with this
with this sort of optimization procedure
so you know a lot of people were talking
about it at that at that program soon
after that been wrecked came and gave a
talk which was actually you know you you
had to dig down to find the same
phenomenon in this paper that's you know
widely known paper by a bunch of folks
at Google where you know their
observation their emphasis was on this
fact that you can actually fit a rather
arbitrary training set into a into a
neural net a standard neural net
architecture without that much that much
effort and and you know they they showed
this is time to overfit for different
training examples one of the striking
things was you could even give random
labels to the to the data this was for a
so far ten data set it's not not written
anywhere but you could even give random
labels you know randomly choosing say 50
percent or a hundred percent of the
labels and you can still find parameters
of the network with stochastic gradient
descent but that fit that fit that
perfectly alright and and you know it's
a bit more it's a bit more effort when
you have totally random labels than when
you have the natural actual image labels
but it's possible
possible to do and the other thing that
you see is that you know as the the
proportion of noise increases of added
noise I should say I mean so far ten so
it's not such a crisp easy to label data
set but as this proportion of added
noise gets increased the performance
degrades now the thing that's not stated
anywhere in the paper and you know you
have to talk to the authors this test
area this is classification loss right
the training error that they talked
about for overfitting overfitting here
means getting a perfect fit they were
also talking about classification loss
but in fact I I don't know for that for
that graph but in fact they were
observing this sort of performance when
it was regression loss as well that was
going to zero so you know that's a
really striking thing you know that
you've injected noise into the end of
the problem right you're then coming up
with zero regression loss so so feeding
the labels exactly these noisy labels
exactly and you're still getting pretty
good pretty good performance when you
when you do that okay so you know that's
that's extraordinary you're taking that
noise and putting it into the parameter
somewhere in a way that doesn't seem to
hurt okay and and you know the other
thing is you've got zero regression loss
so there's no trade-off between
performance on the data and and whatever
notion of complexity you care to you
care to define so you know it's
certainly overfitting there's no better
fitting than to interpolate every data
point but it seems to be benign okay so
you know stepping stepping back from
that I do want to emphasize you know
there are some things that are not so
surprising about about this observation
and some things that I think really are
one thing that really is surprising it's
not so surprising that there are more
parameters than sample size okay that's
what the statisticians call
nonparametric that's not a big deal you
know I mean maybe it's a big deal and
that you there's no explicit effort to
keep control of complexity in this
nonparametric setting but you know there
are certainly implicit efforts of you're
doing stochastic gradient descent
we're going to hear all about implicit
regularization of this sort from from
naughty later in the in the bootcamp so
you know there's that that's not so
extraordinary of course getting good
performance you know I don't know I
guess right getting good performance
with zero classification loss there
might be something else going on hidden
by the fact that classification loss is
ignoring a lot of detail right it may be
that there's a regression loss that's
actually being traded off against
complexity underneath right if you don't
threshold things and look at the
regression loss you know there's at
least room for something to be going on
to be going on there and this is you
know a phenomenon that that as as we
heard in Sasha's talk people have been
been thinking about for decades now the
other thing it's not surprising is if
you get zero regression loss and it's a
problem that has no noise right so the
perceptron example we saw right of the
beanie is exactly that flavor it didn't
just have no noise it had a big margin
right you know okay if if there is a
function in your class of functions if
you want to think of it that way that
gets things absolutely right so there's
no noise in the problem then you know a
perfect fit to the data is totally fine
right so the thing that is really
surprising in all this is we're getting
good performance with zero regression
loss when there's noisy training done it
so you're taking all the noise in those
labels pushing it into the parameters
and hoping that doesn't hurt and turns
out it doesn't hurt the prediction
accuracy so I think that's something
really striking it's you know to my mind
this is a new a new phenomenon that that
that has emerged from from from deep
learning okay so you know this is just
to look at the kind of established
wisdom about fitting a data set
perfectly so sorry you come
for other boost orbiting around the
labels so herb and writing the vapors
lots of excess not all but right Alfred
yeah improving beyond up right so so
adaboost is minimizing this regression
loss it's not getting that to zero right
in in in many of these examples that we
saw the the exponential loss that we saw
this morning the Z to the minus y times
f of X that's the the regression loss
that arises there that's what adaboost
is actually minimizes the convex loss
that's something that's not that's not
going to zero unless you have a zero
noise kind of problem you know that that
I mean that's why if you actually look
at La Crosse central your loss it's also
not going to zero you know miss Club
yeah so so right so I guess this there's
zero in there zero you mean you mean
getting very small values versus versus
taking up room taking parameters off to
infinity to get to get zero values the
aggression setting is DB more yeah right
okay so and I mean I guess there's more
going on if you if you need to take
parameters to infinity to get to get an
actual interpolating solution and that's
a little different from from loss like a
quadratic loss where you can
with with fallout parameters get things
to zero in the temples of boosting
because is at least what such a socially
important I think I'll try it again
tomorrow right for your experience in
boosting you are getting definitely
going to zero loss because you're going
to your junior u16 your opinion air that
x+ will go to zero I can I can show you
the plots what's dis and then keep the
dissimilar a number that is actually
happening very although was because
you're not getting so if we look at this
plot nope next slide it's a little small
isn't it alright so we're getting this
distribution of them of the margins as
that's what so fuzzy okay in in this
part you know this is the margin
distribution after five iterations
here's after a hundred years after a
thousand right and and you know the
difference between a hundred and a
thousand is really very small this is on
a letter data set and and you know the
exponential loss is small here but it's
certainly not going to zero to zero this
definitely deserve because we curated we
will talk about it more tomorrow but
okay one of your loved team will see
tomorrow which is whites and barely
making protocol I'm looking at the Majin
distribution here I say yeah yeah yeah
but the thing is it certainly went to
zero because you're two separate
versions
you're doing for you when you do right
that's right you're right yes okay okay
good so so actually the same phenomenon
this here is present here right good you
notice I was cautious when I was showing
the classification side saying there's
still room for this particular thing so
that's good
okay that's a good point so and and I
guess you're you're going to talk about
those sort of asymptotics for it seems
to me that it's fair to say that
actually it also exists in boosting
accept was not really certainly wasn't
studied right I think it was maybe this
isn't a contribution that deep learning
practice let's give it a special someone
margin even though there was some paper
saying oh actually it's not quite enough
it wasn't like didn't reach good in any
case the point I really wanted to make
was not a historical one so much as you
know this is a phenomenon I think it's
really it's really important and really
interesting and you know really so yet
so maybe I should move the second point
and and you know just just showing just
how ingrained this this view is in in
kind of the statistical mindset at least
you know this is the hasty tips Ronnie
Friedman book it has things like
interpolating fits or unlikely to
predict future data well at all with too
much fitting you know bad things happen
and so on you see it in many many places
something that interpolates the data
hence is not a reasonable estimate an
estimate so okay so this is this is I
think are really important and
interesting phenomenon that you know
training these these kinds of prediction
rules to fit noisy data perfectly still
leads to good predictions okay so so
it's not isolated to neural nets you
know this is an example from a paper of
Sasha's looking at kernel regression on
a digit classification problem and you
see that as you in a kernel regression
problem you have a regularization
parameter that tells you how much the
the norm of the the norm in the hovered
space of your prediction prediction rule
gets taken account of in in in a
trade-off between that and the fit to
the data and as you take this lambda
down to zero that corresponds to
ignoring the regularization right and as
you approach zero you know is seeing the
test error here is getting much better
this is a on a log scale things things
are only improving as that as that
regularization parameter gets small well
this is difficult to see even after I
put it up to full screen on the x axis
is is the you know number of training
iterations again for a linear problem
this is a kernel kernel regression
problem and they're getting you know as
we remove for many of these this is
these are each different data sets as we
move to
to the right we're seeing training
training era the red lines go to you
know essentially zero in in all these
cases in the and the test errors is
improving we're certainly not seeing
this decrease and an increase we're not
seeing any evidence that things are
getting performing poorly as as we get
this better and better fit fit to the
data in in many cases on the right hand
side it's an interpolating fit and and
you know these are these are I'll say
descent methods it's not gradient
descent in many of these plots so you
know we should be thinking of it as as
this training progresses we're doing
less and less regularization you know
there's this close correspondence
between between how far you've gone in
an integrate into senton and some some
notion of the scale of the prediction
and all that you end up with okay so I
want to look at a few three examples so
how many we have 25 minutes so I want to
get three examples where we can say
something about interpolation something
about performance in this sort of in
this sort of setting so one nearest
neighbor is an interpolating prediction
rule it just doesn't happen to have a
small excess risk right you know I guess
this to this to can be improved but it's
still a constant in any in any face
dimension so so you know it's back in
the 60s Kevin Hart showed that that one
nearest neighbor has this this sort of a
guarantee so if if the Bayes risk is
nice and small and then one nearest
neighbor is going to do well so the
noise free case over when there's noise
this particular interpret interpolating
prediction rule doesn't have its risk
approaching the optimal right you're
suffering from interpolating the noisy
labels
but there's this work of Daniel who's
here somewhere hiding over here Daniel
and and collaborators broken Dimitra on
a variant of one nearest neighbor and
the way this works is to take a sort of
a simplicial partition of space defined
by the sample so so one nearest neighbor
you know you might have three three
neighbors close to a point here and and
you would can consider the closest one
in in this simplicity interpolation
scheme they take this partition so
partition the space into simplices so in
two dimensions
you look at the the the three points
whose convex hull you're contained in
the test point is contained in your
partitioning the space according to all
of these simplices and then you're
predicting using the the generators of
the convex hull that you're in right so
if i'm here and these are the these are
the three three points in this
simplicity of partition then i'm going
to predict using the labels associated
with those points but i don't just pick
the nearest neighbors label i pick the
linear function defined by those by
those three or those D plus one and D
dimensions okay which has the nice
property that at any one of these points
you know at any point in the sample I'm
actually interpolating right the linear
function of course goes through the
values at those points so it is an
interpolating prediction scheme the the
nice thing is that you know under some
under some assumptions you can show that
the excess risk or equivalently this is
in the again in the squared error case
the the the expectation of the
difference between a square difference
between our prediction under this scheme
and and the the Bayes rules prediction
goes down like you know there's a
variance term just think of that as a
constant times constant over d write
something something like 1 over d excuse
me so so so somehow in high dimensions
you know you're getting you're getting
something that's that's closer and
closer to optimal as the as that I
mentioned goes up right I mean it's not
it's not telling you that for any fixed
dimension you'll approach the optimal
starboard but as the dimension gets gets
larger you and and the intuition I guess
is that for this sort of interpolation
compared to nearest neighbor nearest
neighbor has you know some very
significant fraction of this simplex
where it's it's deciding to predict
according to this guy's label
whereas this simplicity interpolation
you know it's it's doing the the linear
function but it's you know if you think
about it as being what's the impact of a
noisy point a you know a bad label on on
this thing compared to what the f star
would look like which is in some sense
the average of the the nearby labels you
know in in high dimensions that that
impact is is small and it's sort of a 1
over the kind of fraction okay
the second approach I want to talk about
as local kernel smoothing so this is
Sasha's work with Misha Belkin and and
such a fever cough so this is looking at
you know again these not Araya what's
and kernel smoothing kinds of estimates
but instead of using something that that
looks like you know that is bounded they
consider these crazy kernels that go to
infinity at the data points right so at
these excise they look at kernels that
that go like one over the the distance
to 2 X I so you know so we have this
singularity at this point X I that thing
goes off to infinity like 1 over the
norm to some power and and you know if
you think about what that that weighted
sum looks like right you're making your
your forecast
according to Y I times W WI of X which
for your test point is saying you know
what's the what's this kernel look like
centered at X I for my test point X and
dividing that by the sum of these WI X's
okay so you get a proportion of the Y's
but if we make this WI go to infinity at
the data point X I then as X passes
through X I that one dominates and we
get exactly why I we get an
interpolating prediction right
min of that yeah yeah I wasn't even
referring to it but yes this doesn't go
to infinity yet but you know the the
analysis that we saw we saw before you
know it ignore clipping it just think
about think about this thing that
actually goes to infinity and then the
weighted sum you know really does
emphasize only the one that the the
point that you're at when when X is at X
is you predict just Y I so you get an
interpolating solution
on the bandwidth that you choose you
know you might move very rapidly away
from that interpolating solution but
still you're getting you're getting a F
hat that passes through weii at every
exit and and you know if you think
through the argument that we gave it
still goes through so so you know
actually memorizing the the data doesn't
harm that sort of bias-variance tradeoff
argument and and this paper showed
actually that if you choose the
bandwidth appropriately you can still
get these votes okay so you know I I
think it feels like a very unnatural
kind of interpolating prediction
strategy here using these these kernels
they seem like a bit of a curiosity but
you know it's certainly a demonstration
that you can interpolate and still get
good good statistical performance out of
it you know I mean maybe it's worth
being cautious about that right I could
come up with an interpolating prediction
rule that performs well by giving you a
standard RK Ches kind of scheme and then
saying oh but it's a two-step process
first of all I'll check if x equals 1 of
the X is and then return y:i otherwise
I'll give you the prediction that might
my kernel method gives you it's not so
interesting right
it's an interpolating prediction method
but feels a little unnatural
oh yeah so here that's right that's
right the dimension you don't you you
know so this this result is is saying
you know we actually don't approach F
star and but we get close to it
particularly if D is very big yeah so
this is a weaker result this one says
you know we do haven't written it down
anywhere but you know the the result
that was given about the analysis of
these kernel smoothing estimates you
know the same same style of analysis
goes through so you're getting this this
the dimension appears in the in the
rates right because we're making this
this particular Lipschitz assumption but
you know it's not like there's a gap
between the performance as there is here
you know there's a gap between your
performance and the optimal performance
in this case and that's not true you can
get the optimal rates for instance
certainly asymptotically you get the
excess risk going to zero other
questions
all right so I want to say a bit about
two pieces of work on linear regression
so this is you can think of it as being
in in Hilbert space to start with think
of it as a reproducing kernel Hilbert
space and and doing a minimum norm
interpolation so you know if we're in
one of these settings where we have the
freedom to to interpolate the data to
get everything right and of course there
are typically many many solutions that
are possible right and the and the lower
bounds from the the the talk that that
Sasha gave show us that actually yeah
and I guess my talk show that that you
know you can certainly find solutions
that will perform very badly all right
but but you know so we need to specify a
particular interpolating solution so
let's pick the one that has the smallest
norm in in the first case in the arc HS
and so it's you know in some sense the
in in precisely this sense the smoothest
to the minimal
interpolating solution and you know you
can write it in a closed-form way in
terms of a kernel kernel matrix this is
the empirical the the gram matrix right
the matrix of inner products between the
the points in the in the training set
take the inverse of that times this is
the vector of labels and then this is
the vector of inner products between the
test point X and and and the training
data those are the predictions you're
making when you want to do this minimum
norm interpolation and and working with
a gradient flow gives you something
that's that's really close to this
minimum warm solution asymptotic okay so
we're going to consider that that case
and this is this is Sasha's work with
ten Ewan Liang so the case they were
considering was a kernel had had the
form you know K of UV was some function
of the inner product between U and V
this is a Euclidean inner product so you
know maybe this is like a polynomial or
something but it's some it's some
function that has some curvature right
so kernels of this form and these UVs
are from Rd right and and then you know
under some properties of the way the
this X is the is the matrix of data in
the in the D dimensional space so so you
know when you know something about the
way that that data lies if d is large if
the if the fire has a nice curvature
then you can get bounds on the
performance of this interpolated
solution where the interesting term is
this this bias term that that depends on
an effective dimension the effective
dimension looks like you know this is
the sum across the D dimensions in the
in the input space of eigen values of
this matrix right so this is the gram
matrix
right / the same thing plus a gamma
where the gamma appears in the curvature
of this Phi so we're sort of a parameter
of the problem that arises from the
kernel there in this specific regime
where they can apply random matrix
Theory results where the the dimension D
here and the sample size are going to
infinity in some sets together you know
asymptotically they're like a constant
factor apart yes if you want to think of
it as doing gradient descent it is but
you know actually the analysis is all
about this explicit closed form solution
for the linear case you know we know how
to solve least squares problems it's X
transpose X to the minus One X transpose
Y all right this is the kernel form of
that but but we want a minimum normal
solution that's not something we can
invert so we say X transpose X pseudo
inverse X transpose Y and that's exactly
what we look at and and what's what's
analyzed in such as maybe if you want to
think about it as what happens here to
get that minimum normal solution and yes
you should start at zero
okay and you know this has some nice
parallels to what goes on when you think
about the ridge regression right you you
get a very similar kind of affective
dimension arising in a Ridge regression
problem where this lambda is the
regularization parameter in your Ridge
regression where you say you know I want
to minimize the squared error plus
lambda times the l2 norm squared of my
parameters that lambda appears there and
you're getting you know something that
might be smaller than the dimension
okay and I guess so
so things depend on properties of the of
the empirical kernel matrix the eigen
values of the empirical kernel matrix
have appeared and not empirical kernel
matrix the this gram matrix in the input
space on that previous slide and then in
terms of what actually happens for a
particular situation when you have some
information about the population you
know what what does the covariance
matrix look like for these vectors in d
space you know these are some
experiments that these guys did that
where you know if you have the
eigenvalues of the covariance matrix
before you put it through this
transformation going decreasing at
certain rates then you know different
things happen there there seems to be an
optimal value if things decrease too
fast it's not good if they decrease too
slow it's not good and in between it's
somehow somehow better I think so
totally clear you know what's what's
going on what you can conclude about the
empirical gram matrix and it's its
impact on the problem under these sort
of assumptions on the Vitara but is that
good choice
yeah all right questions so I remember
if I remember the analysis it's in
looking at l2 risk is that the root
that's not when I think about the
failure that could potentially happen
interpolation I I guess my I think our
intuition but it's more visually about L
infinity right it is maybe that l2 you
know noise is noise you're taking taking
the noise from the labels and you're
putting it into your
one of these parameters so it's what you
know see it's still in l2 that that you
expect that to be a harmful thing yeah
but I know anyway you cannot hope to get
that one didn't see a consistent
solution because we go through the noise
so is that that's the constant gap yeah
of course of course but I'm but I guess
I'm sorry I'm defending l2 rather than
yes rather than attacking Allatoona and
then also in you know when we think
about when people draw pictures and
interpolating solutions all the book
solution all the book pictures you gave
for one dimensions in my dimensions your
data paths are may be very far away and
then the active interpolating isn't
quite so absurd yeah isn't isn't so
absurd and I think that's the message
from you know this this work that Daniel
did on the simplicity later
interpolation yeah yeah high dimensions
it's not so
okay oh yeah so should we think about
should permit ization as as a way that
like this all these you know parameters
are just learning the noise and some
others are learning this let me get on
to it let me get on to that so I think
that's a really good way of thinking of
it so also sasha has with with a student
some lower bounds for a specific a
specific kernel that says that I guess
bottom line is you can't hope to do
anything unless you're in general anyway
you know we're fit for this sort of
kernel you can't hope to do anything
unless you're in a high dimensional
setting when you're working working with
this sort of a kernel interpolating
escape
what add anything yeah but the this is
exactly this thing that in high
dimensional things are more forgiving
right right in high dimensions you pay
less the the the one dimensional picture
is misrepresenting things that the
interpolating points are not are not so
crazy as it eventually gets higher on
the other hand for any constant
dimension this is
this is bad
okay and the connection and neural
networks I'd hoped to be able to skip
through this and say you saw all these
definitions in Jason's talk this morning
but then Jason didn't oblige and he's
going to he's going to talk about this
tomorrow so I'm just going to skip over
it and say look out tomorrow for for a
particular kernel that appears in the
setting of random initialization with
very wide networks you know wider than
the sample size you know you don't have
to move very far and so you can think of
the linearization as essentially all you
can give all you can compute with a
stochastic gradient sort of method right
so there is you know think of that
linearization as you know it's it's
defining a class of linear functions
that's the best the bottom line I don't
need to go through the details of that
see Jason's talk tomorrow
okay the last thing I want to talk about
in in the last five minutes and this is
work that that I've done with Phil Don
Garber lugozshe and Alexandre Ziegler
who's somewhere in the audience over
here so so this is looking at linear
regression let's think of it as finite
dimensional it's true in in Hilbert
space as well
let's say Gaussian it makes the so you
know makes everything more convenient
but I I think we can get everything to
go through for the sub Gaussian case so
just think about XY jointly Gaussian
means zero then the parameters of our
linear regression problem are the
covariance matrix of our X's and in
particular their eigenvalues right so
think of the lambda rise as a decreasing
sequence of eigenvalues that's all the
information we need because everything
is this sort of Direction independent we
can work with whatever basis we like so
it's just the eigenvalues that matter
there's a theta star there's a
least-squares parameter vector and all
we really use about that is that it's
got a finite norm and there's some level
of noise right and it's positive so
we're not talking about this sort of
easy zero noise case our estimator is
the interpolating one so we're
of the case where actually lambda n is
bigger than zero so we can find we can
find an interpolating solution right and
and the least square solution you know
this is solving the least squares
problem but minimum norm we're taking
the pseudo inverse of X transpose X and
multiplying that by X transpose Y so
okay so it solves this least squares
think of it as minimum norm such that
you solve a least squares problem but
we're interested in the case where you
know that solution to the least squares
problem is 0 we're interpolating
everything so we need to have you know
enough of these directions so we're
asking you know when can the label noise
be hidden in the parameter estimates
without hurting predictive accuracy and
of course you know this is the quality
you care about else L foetus had - I'm
writing theta hat rather than our FN hat
- L star so it's this excess prediction
risk and of course it depends just on
how how far we are from the least
squares parameter vector weighted the
directions are weighted according to
these lambdas right that's one one role
that the the covariance matrix plays
it's telling us how much an error in a
you know parameter estimate you know in
a direction in parameter space affects
predictive accuracy so here's the
theorem there are Universal constants so
that for any linear regression problem
we need to have theta star bounded norm
so the least square solution you know is
it's finite noise level and and our
covariance matrix this is where all the
action happens we want to be able to
interpolate then you can say the
expected excess prediction risk the
expected excess risk is bounded above
and below there's a term here that's
just the classical term about getting
the signal right right getting the theta
star to be accurately approximated by
our Peter hat
that's that's more standard this term
and and in the lower bound also is the
is where all the action is this is the
impact of the noise on the parameters
and we get upper and lower bounds so
this is exactly what's going on and and
you know what are these things mean well
there's a noise level there's there
differ by constants there are two terms
k star over N and n over some notion of
effective rank and the K star is defined
in terms of some other notion of
effective rank so let me explain what
it's only in the upper bound I mean I'm
presumably yeah I guess we haven't tried
very hard and getting that into the
lower bound that's the in some sense
less interesting part right if you do
this by experience decomposition this is
the part that tells you how much error
do you get from the theta star three
theta star transpose X part of the
labels and the other part is telling you
how much error do you get from the noise
okay so so K star is how how many
dimensions you have to go through before
the effective rank of the orthogonal
subspace is bigger than something like n
and I'll say what that means and then up
here we need this effective rank to be
big compared to end if you want that
quantity to be small so what are these
effective ranks you know they're saying
ignore everything up to K dimensions the
the highest variance directions and
beyond there look at the the l1 norm of
the eigenvalues in that subspace divided
by the biggest of them you know infinity
norm and this capital R is looking at
the l1 norm squared divided by the l2
norm squared all right so it's just like
you know if you think about let me give
an example if you're in finite
dimensions right then it's rank times
some notion of symmetry right so in in
the two cases there different notions of
symmetry but these s quantities s and
capital A sly between you know 1 over P
and 1 right 1 over P is when you really
only have one direction where anything's
happening and one is where things are
spherical so it's sort of you know if
you're very symmetric then it's just the
rank if you're very asymmetric then it
could be much smaller than that in
particular you can go off to infinity
and it's
the effective effective rank in that
sense okay so if we go back in and look
at the theorem very quickly right you
need the effective you need to go
through ke ke dimensions to get the
effective rank big compared to n K
better not be too big compared to N and
then you want this other effective rank
big compared to N and you know if you
think about that that K star being you
know you you can draw a bunch of
conclusions so the noise energy has to
be distributed across lots of
unimportant directions which addresses
your your question in a very precise way
they have to be lots of nonzero
eigenvalues they should have a small sum
compared to the sample size and there
should be lots of eigenvalues that are
not much bigger than you know this
lambda k star the point at which you you
cut off so you need a sort of rather
constant tail of many many eigenvalues
in the covariance in order to be able to
hide the noise in those directions and
you know it's an if and only if they're
upper and lower bounds but okay and this
is my second last it's like so yeah so
this this terminology overfitting i mean
these are cases where you're feeling
perfectly so there's no there's no I
mean over sounds pejorative but you know
you're certainly pit fitting the data
perfectly but but it's benign
overfitting it's it's a very different
thing from having bias to low and
variants to high it could be a very
different thing you know so for instance
if those conditions about the
eigenvalues are satisfied then fitting
the data perfectly is totally fine in
linear regression if they're not
satisfied then indeed you're you're
suffering from having variance too high
but you know they're they're different
things the fit to the data versus
whether you suffering from high bias
variance that's too high
something questions it for the plus
serum if you were to sita is infinite
dimensional and you're always and others
are positive does the theorem quite that
you estimated through sega system with
let me pull up with their imagine oh
yeah
there's nothing about to mention here
actually i mean i think i i don't i
don't think i was explicit on the first
slide but you can just be working in a
hilbert space yeah I mean like I know
there's a positive that the theorem say
there You've has to meet the true seer
consistently that's right this term is
telling you how is telling you the the
impact of the theta star transpose X X I
terms on on the thea hat and and saying
that the error that's caused by the
distorted view that the the sample
covariance if you want to think of it
that way gives you of theta star is not
too bad as long as the trace the sum of
all those infinitely many eigenvalues is
not it is dominated by n right does that
answer your question I think what it is
if because your arrow the XS arrow is
like the worm between the estimated
theta hat and
data yes that's right is large then
basically saying that under winds lunge
a is large when your sample size is
large basically saying that your theta
hat is close to the truth data in the
norm defined by Sigma that's right so
the Sigma here plays those lambdas play
two roles one role is that they they
determine where the noise in the labels
get spread out among among the parameter
vector and the other all they play is
the one you're referring to that that
actually the excess loss here is is a
measure of the error of your parameters
but it's weighted by those those eigen
values so there are some directions with
small eigen values that don't matter at
all right you can have big errors in
those directions and actually you know
this seems to be what's what the
adversarial example story is all about
because you've got a direction with a
huge amount of noise right order n
magnitude in that direction but it
doesn't matter at all so in the interest
of time let's take the rest the
questions offline and we'll be back in
about 17 minutes
[Applause]